- Oh (bleep), oh (bleep),
oh (bleep), oh.
(upbeat music)
- Hey guys, my name's Eric.
I'm new here,
so I thought I'd make some
friends around the office
by giving people a little
treat I grew up with in Russia.
Chocolate with a full shot of vodka in it.
What were they called?
- Let's go get it.
Welcome to Russia Town.
(Russian music)
Let's go make some friends.
- Chocolate with a bagel?
- Now when you say you're
trying to make friends
around the office,
that makes me think that
this is gonna be from
some pretty gnarly stuff right here.
- I guess that's the best
way to make some new friends,
right?
Give 'em random chocolate in a cup.
- If I'm being stereotypical,
I'd ask if you placed
vodka in the chocolate.
- I'm expecting like really
strong dark chocolate.
- It could be vodka in it,
potatoes,
cyanide.
- It's not even noon.
I hope that's not vodka.
- I really it's not like
Russian meat.
Mmm, gross.
- Uh.
- Oh god, it's so...
Ugh.
- It's wet.
- I just took a bite and it's like,
vodka squirted out everywhere.
- Did you have this as a kid?
- The video didn't record.
You're gonna have to do it again.
So what are you expecting?
- I'm expecting to be very unhappy, again.
- That's good.
- I'd just take these
to the club, be like,
"Oh, what's that in your bag?
"Nothing, just chocolate."
- The chocolate itself
is good.
I think I just was so expecting
a creamy center.
- Caramel would have been nice.
- This is actually really good.
It's got a good texture.
Good vod,
good vodka, I think.
Yeah.
- Hey Russia, what's goin' on?
I know we're havin' some difficult times
between us right now,
but I really think you kind of
start selling this over here,
I feel like we can kind of
work our differences out.
- So I want more friends,
so I'm just gonna run around the office
and give this chocolate to anybody.
- Mmm, aw.
Uh uh.
- If I get you drunk,
will we be best friends?
- Are we best friends?
That's lit.
- That's lit!
- You want chocolate?
- Yeah.
Mmm, I like it.
- Are we gonna party
with some of this later?
Do you wanna get chocolate
drunk and be my friend?
You like it?
Are we best friends?
She's my best friend.
(Russian music)
- How do you say cheers in Russian?
(speaks in Russian)
(Russian music)